para que las acusaciones de crímenes de
guerra en ucrania no queden archivadas
como ocurrió con los casos de las
víctimas del estado islámico en irak y
siria el fiscal de la corte penal
internacional abrió una investigación
sobre ucrania justo después de la
invasión rusa del 24 de febrero y
asegura que existe una base suficiente
para constatar las violaciones al
derecho internacional humanitario
este es nuestro momento para hablar es
un momento para la acción en el derecho
internacional humanitario no puede ser
un espectador pasivo deberíamos
sentirnos avergonzados que en 2022
sigamos viendo en tantas partes del
mundo violencia que puede convertirse en
genocidio crímenes contra la humanidad
crímenes de guerra
el fiscal de la cpi pidió acciones a los
países que integran el consejo de
seguridad de la onu durante la sesión se
cuestionó la capacidad de acción que
tiene el organismo
ucrania es hoy un matadero justo en el
corazón de europa
a mí me da vergüenza que no haya un
sistema de justicia que responde a las
violaciones y matanzas masivas
la corte penal internacional tiene
potestad para investigar y enjuiciar a
individuos que han cometido crímenes de
guerra y no a los estados y los jueces
de la cpi pueden emitir órdenes de
arresto sin embargo el tribunal no tiene
su propia fuerza policial y depende de
los estados miembros para arrestar a los
sospechosos
rusia no es miembro de la corte pues se
retiró en 2016 sin embargo los
investigadores de la cpi pueden analizar
las denuncias actuales e incluso las
pasadas que se remontan a 2014 tras la
elección de crimea por parte de rusia
debido a una solicitud que hizo ucrania
en aquel entonces y que sumarían como
material de evidencia